I've been reading a lot of information about diemethyl sulfoxide, DMSO, and the healing properties for both external and internal use.
What are your thoughts on DMSO?
Well, DMSO came out back in the 70s. It was really popular as an anti-inflammatory topical.
It's literally like water in its viscosity and it's easy and cheap to buy on Amazon and anybody can get it.
It could be as strong anti-inflammatory but it can be a methyl donor and definitely a sulfur donor.
People used to like lather up their knee when they hurt their knee or they hurt their wrist and they're going to splatter it all over their wrist and understand it literally is like water.
If you open up the bottle it literally pours water and you could dump it all over your body.
The negative is that it's a methyl donor. It is an anti-inflammatory but it is a sulfur donor as well which can have negative effects depending upon if you have a lot of CBS gene defects.
You could push that pathway hard and you could end up with issues and I have multiple videos of that if you have a CBS over production or under production and that could be an issue with people.
But using it topically or even orally for a very short period of time typically that's not going to be an issue.
Because it's a sulfur donor you also will get the taste of garlic and your mouth very strongly and like immediately following.
DMS also absorbs almost instantaneously through the skin doing topically and that's how it can be very beneficial in decreasing inflammation and enjoyed or like if you have a swollen knuckle or if you have rheumatoid arthritis it can be beneficial.
The negative of it is that it's kind of like any other product like we've talked about methylene blue or we've even talked to do we can even use the same discussion with men does all and I've erected is that there's people that go and write a little short little book about the benefits of DMS or I've erected or some people based their practice on these things.
And they also have toxic side effects because DMSO can be a methyl donor. It can be it can basically turn off your tumor suppressor system.
But because it's so anti inflammatory it can help a cancer as well. So there's a danger in doing a DMSO topically over let's say a breast cancer.
Because in one sense the positive side it could be area anti inflammatory and take down the inflammation that's around that a growing cancer so that your immune system can get at and kill it that would be the positive side.
And there is a negative side to so many of these things. So this isn't a natural supplement that is not going to have any negative things or it's not going to spare normal cells and it's going to have it's going to change your physiology.
It's changing the what's going on metabolically in your body. So just like doing chemo chemo can kill cancer but chemo can also kill other cells chemo is going to kill your any rapidly growing cells, which are your immune system.
So the catch 22 with chemo is that it can damage your body. It can it can kill you.
So you do chemo very carefully and sparingly so that you don't kill the patient before you kill the cancer and you're and and you're very careful with that.
Well, you have to be just as careful what's been bend is all and I remember back then and just as careful with something even simple that you could buy an Amazon like DMSO because it could have a negative effect because the metal groups could then be shutting off the intrinsic a poptonic pathway.
It could actually assist the growth of the cancer so the cancer isn't being killed from the inside out.
Does that mean I wouldn't use it? No, it doesn't mean I wouldn't use it, but I'd be careful using it. So if I was going to put it on at first of all, I probably would not use DMSO orally.
Now, I know you could find some articles that DMSO can help with decrease cancer. They think it helps kill cancer. I don't think so. I think it decreases inflammation around the cancer. So like I mentioned it can have a positive effect.
It can also have a negative effect. It's the same thing with Iverbacter. You hear all this stuff about Iverbacter and Iverbacter and Iverbacter and Iverbacter and Femme does all Femme does all it.
Okay, it doesn't work on everybody and it can be caused ill effects on some people. It's not this magic thing.
That affects so much of Iverbacter that you could purchase now is tainted with all sorts of stuff that affects you negatively. It's still a drug.
So if you're going to use DMSO, use it sparingly, start really small. Just be very careful, just like anything else, be extremely careful.
Typically, functional doctors over the years have used DMSO as a driver. So they're like put zinc in DMSO, like we have a zinc product with DMSO that we only sell to patients and it's only to patients that I'm allowing to use.
And that's driving zinc into the site because DMSO is absorbs like instantaneously through the skin.
It also drags with it anything that's around it. That's why what are the cardinal rules with using DMSO.
Typically, which typically they don't already ever tell you this is you got to make sure your skin is extremely clean, especially women who use lotions and stuff might have chemicals in it.
You put DMSO on with the top of that. You're basically driving those chemicals right into your tissue and into your bloodstream.
So you either have a very clean surface or if you're trying to drive something in there, you then you maybe put down an essential oil or you're using zinc in the DMSO to drive a specific thing into the tissue.
So there's a purpose for all these things and they can have wonderful benefits, right? But they could also have side effects.
You know, that's why, okay, if you're going to use curcumin, is that, are you going to have side effects to that?
Well, only if you have anybody to that, which is going to be a very small percentage of people, you have like an alert sensitivity to curcumin.
Which, you know, you can have a sensitivity to anything, right?
But if you're using a high dose curcumin or high dose burberry or, you know, things like that, it's going to spare healthy cells.
I've even, even something like, like Lea trill. Okay, Lea trill, is that a drug?
Well, I don't think so. No, that's a nutrient that's found in aproposites. It's not a drug. It doesn't kill healthy cells.
Yeah, if you take 10 of them, could you have ill effects of them? Yes.
But, you know, take it in the right dose and you're, it spares healthy cells.
They can selenium in a higher dose read my article and harness it, oxidative stress to kill cancer.
You'll see a lot of higher dose supplements act as oxidative agents to cancer cells, but don't act as oxidative agents to healthy cells.
So they don't cause oxidative damage to healthy cells. They spare healthy cells while helping kill cancer cells.
I know dealt with this for the 25 years that I've been dealing 28 years, I've been dealing with cancer patients.
And it's, there's all sorts of fads that come out on the market that everybody needs to be on this.
Everybody needs to be on rick Simpson oil. Everybody needs to be on Fendman.
Everybody needs to be on I've elected. I'm about to say there's that you can't try things and they can be miraculous to people.
But everybody doesn't need to be on anything. You know, so it's just you gotta go slow with these things to make sure you don't have side effects.